here's what we came up with remember
this is by no means the only way to
build this site I'm sure your sites look
totally different than this one and that
is totally cool like always when I
started working on this I started with a
small viewport at a glance the most
noticeable improvement is the fact that
the text is now a lot larger this is a
nice change to help improve readability
as to the new location column in the
sports score table well it disappeared
on mobile when there's enough room for
the locations I went ahead and added
display block to the location class to
make them show back up when the viewport
is now in the desktop range I decided to
shrink the text in the sports table to
make room for the location while I would
rather make a totally different snazzier
table to make everything fit I thought
that making the font smaller was a nice
compromise to keep all the information I
wanted in the table next on my list of
changes is the latest news section in
the old version I didn't really like the
way the text was wrapping around these
images and I also didn't like the fact
that these images were just so small I
decided to give myself a little bit of
flexibility so I turned each article or
snip it into a flex box you can tell
that at the smaller screen size I've
totally dropped the thumbnail images and
I've gone ahead and cropped the text to
three lines adding this ellipsis here to
the end of the last line isn't super
simple actually so if you want to do the
same I suggest starting with the link
that you can find in the instructor
notes as the page gets wider the images
show back up and they scale with the
width of the page next up I tackle the
thumbnail images for the articles
originally these images were being
scaled down from an image that was
something like 2,000 by 1400 pixels
which is just absolutely massive and way
too big for this use so i used image
processing software to scale the image
down to twice the resolution of the
largest resolution these thumbnails
could take with this layout thumbnails
don't get any larger than 245 by 1 64
pixels high density displays need high
density images so i scaled the image
down to 4 90 x 3 27 pixels which is a
much smaller file to learn more about
using images responsively and
responsibly try our responsive images
course made by google Sam Dutton for the
final version of this project I put all
of my code into final CSS it's
essentially just a series of breakpoints
and then small changes to the snippets
and scores I'm not going to go into
depth with my coat at the moment but the
instructor notes has instructions on how
to download and play with my source code
all in all I'm pretty happy with my copy
of the Brighton times but this is just
my layout I want to see what you've done
to make sure that you post all of your
sites in the forums